hello and welcome to Madeira fight in
this video we will discuss why do we get
acne and how to treat acne in the end we
will also discuss some at home remedies
that you can do to prevent and treat
acne at home so let's begin
I am dr. Umar and I am the creator of
this channel med simplify it I'm doing
my MD in dermatology only and I thought
why not make a video on the topic of
acne itself as more than forty to fifty
percent of young sirs all across the
globe suffer from acne I myself has
suffered from great for acne in my teen
ages and to this day it carried the
scars of those acne which will probably
never go away well that being said let's
begin with today's video in which we
will discuss about acne we will begin
with some interesting facts about acne
and then we will talk about how acne
develop we will discuss the role of pilo
sebaceous unit and the role of
testosterone and diet in acne so let's
begin with some important facts about
acne acne is the most common skin
condition in United States according to
the Academy of Dermatology mild to
moderate acne affects 40 to 50 million
Americans per year and while acne
usually begins in the puberty and
affects almost 90% of teenagers acne is
not restricted to any age group
in fact acne affects 20% of adults
between the ages of 25 and 44 the most
common bacteria that is involved in acne
is the Propionibacterium acne which is
the gram-positive bacteria present on
human skin as a part of normal flora as
well in the oral cavity in the large
intestine conjunctiva and external ear
canal meaning that this bacteria is a
normal bacteria on our skin and only in
conditions where acne formation is
favored this bacteria colonizes and
causes inflammation so to understand
acne in the first place you will have to
understand about this structure in your
skin and this is known as the pile of
sebaceous unit look at all the small
hair shafts on your face these hair
shafts correspond to this structure in
the illustration of a pile of sebaceous
unit here you can see a cut section of
the skin showing the pile of sebaceous
unit now look at the water itself
pile of sebaceous it is made up of
towards
by low meaning hair and sebaceous
because this structure also contains a
sebaceous gland which is connected to
the hair follicle the sebaceous gland is
a small oil-producing gland of her skin
which does the job of lubrication of our
skin they secrete an oily secretion
known as sebum and in addition to his
role as protective barrier that reduces
skin dehydration sebum also possesses
antibacterial properties
the sebaceous glands are distributed
over the entire body with the exception
of palms and soles they are most
abundant on the scalp and face under
normal circumstances small amounts of
sebum is produced which is necessary to
keep your skin moist another factor that
contributes to the development of acne
is skin shedding our skin cells are shed
continuously with a cycle of about 56
days the same shedding of cells also
occurs in the topmost portion of the
hair follicle this is important as this
contributes to one of the important
factors why acne develops now let's
understand how acne is formed from this
pile of sebaceous unit and before that I
would just like to mention that you can
join our channel and get the ultimate
guide to remove acne which is a six page
ebook and covers face mapping charts
zones of acne and ten extra tips that
will help you to maintain an acne free
skin so click the join button below to
know more age is a very important factor
for the development of acne as soon as
you hit puberty your testosterone levels
go like this and just like we discussed
earlier testosterone is one of the main
hormones that controls the amount of
sebum produced by the sebaceous glands
the amount of sebum produced by the
sebaceous glands increases when you hit
puberty
next comes the role of bacteria and
other pathogens in the formation of your
acne
these include Propionibacterium acnes
species and many others but
Propionibacterium acnes is the most
abundant so to summarise up till now we
have identified many factors as to why
acne develop age being the driving
factor which leads to an increase in the
levels of testosterone in your blood
skin cells shedding also occurs and then
we discuss about the role of bacteria in
acne now what happens is that when
glands produce too much oil the pores
can become blocked and dirt bacteria and
cells build up the blockage is called a
plug or a comment on if the top of the
plug is white it is called a Whitehead
and at the top of the plug is dark it is
referred to as blackhead black color is
due to keratin plug that gets fixed on
the poor of the pile of sebaceous unit a
white head is due to us
all collection of pus in the follicle
opening once the plug occurs
Propionibacterium acnes starts to grow
in the follicle the bacterium then sets
off a cascade of inflammation and the
plug becomes red and bigger and
ultimately turns into a pimple when the
inflammation doesn't stop the acne
becomes even bigger and goes deeper into
the skin ultimately becoming assist so
this is how acne is formed upon reaching
a certain age your hormone levels start
to rise which triggers an increase in
the sebum production by the sebaceous
glands
this combined with follicular plugging
by shed skin cells and infiltration of
bacteria into the pile of spacious unit
leads to formation of acne or in
layman's language a pimple now I wish it
were that simple because in this way all
of us should have acne males have high
levels of testosterone at the time of
puberty females also have many types of
hormones like DHEA s testosterone etc so
by that logic almost 100% of people
should have acne but there is a big but
here there are many other factors that
also determine whether you will develop
acne or not some of them are clearly
known and some of them are being still
researched for example stress oily and
unhealthy foods dairy products skipping
meals cosmetics are some of the
well-known exaggerating factors for
development of acne other factors which
are known to cause acne include food
allergies that can include allergies to
dairy products iodine gluten or biotin
underlying health problems can also
cause acne
these include thyroid problems PCOS
Diabetes digestive imbalances and
metabolism issues but some factors are
still debatable or questionable as many
factors are considered to be a cause of
acne but most of them are not
scientifically proven so now we have
understood how acne is formed we have
understood some of the exaggerating
factors and Before we jump on to the
treatment of acne it is very important
for you to understand the four grades of
acne acne are divided into four grades
with increasing severity of the lesions
grade one include comma downs and few
papules
papules being raised lesions less than
one centimeter great - acne includes
whiteheads whiteheads are also known as
pustules which are small pus filled acne
but that we commonly know as whiteheads
and create three agnese when you start
developing few nodules along with
whiteheads nodular lesions are more than
one centimeter and are solid red raised
lesions which have active inflammation
in them grade four is when you get the
uglier looking type of acne and these
are the nodules and the cysts
inflammation is marked and there will be
a lot of papules and pustules over the
face plus scarring is permanent in this
grade so by now you would have probably
put yourself in grade 1 grade 2 or grade
4 depending upon the acne you have let's
start with how to treat acne in this I
will be talking about topical medicines
you can apply on your face face hygiene
and oral medicines and when and how you
should take them and a lot more and then
in the end we will discuss about some of
the best lifestyle changes you can do
and add home remedies that you can apply
which will give you the best results for
your acne so stay tuned till the end the
treatment depends upon the severity of
the acne and that is why I introduced
you to these various grades of acne as
different grades of acne have different
treatment options let's start with the
basics so if you have grade 1 acne your
basic treatment options are only topical
medications that you can apply on your
face I recommend a simple topical
retinoid cream and a salicylic acid face
wash to be applied twice daily the
nighttime application of any cream is
more beneficial as it gives the cream
more time and space to absorb deeply
into your skin
retinoids normalize the cell cycle of
the keratinocytes and also do a host of
other things that are beneficial for a
person who has acne on the face the most
commonly used are adapt lean in the
concentration of 0.1 to 0.3 which is
applied twice daily on the face it comes
in gels creams and lotions for you to
choose from and from the day you start
application you will see the results in
a few weeks
salicylic acid face wash is important as
it helps to peel off the topmost layer
of
cells on your face as well as it also
reduces the stickiness of individual
cells with each other in comedone
extraction or comment on extractor
instrument is placed central to the
comment on and affirm downward pressure
is applied as a result unwanted material
then comes out from the comment on now I
want to discuss a very important topic
for the management of acne and that is
face hygiene this includes washing your
face two to three times a day with a
good salicylic acid containing face wash
and depending upon the skin type using a
particular moisturizer washing your face
in the night is particularly important
as it cleanses your skin and then you
can apply a moisturizer and then the
subsequent topical medications after
that you are not exposed to sunlight or
any form of pollution so the medicines
that you can apply on your face get
ample amount of time to work in your
skin not touching your face with your
hands as this transmits several
pathogenic bacteria from your hands to
your face these tips are to be followed
in all grades of acne so most of the
grade 1 acne you respond to this minimal
treatment of simple facial hygiene and
topical medications and show a good
response within 2 weeks of treatment
next we move on to the treatment of
grade 2 acne and if you remember grade 2
acne is when we start seeing whiteheads
and onward blackheads and in this also
you can follow the same treatment we
used for grade 1 acne in addition to
topical retinoids there are several
topical medications that can be used in
grade 2 acne
these include PPO or benzoyl peroxide
topical antibiotics and as alloc acid
let's look at them one by one and see
which one you should follow BPO or
benzoyl peroxide is a very good topical
antibacterial agent that is effective
against Propionibacterium acnes and
other bacteria that cause infection in
the pilo sebaceous unit it is available
in 2 point 5 to 10% formulations for you
to choose from choose a good face wash
that contains BPO and salicylic acid in
balanced combination that gives you the
best result I have included some links
in the description below for you to
choose from
the combination of 0.1% atop lean and
2.5 percent benzoyl peroxide provides
much better and faster results as
compared to the individual drugs alone
as a leak acid is a potent
anti-inflammatory topical drug that you
can apply for acne
I recommend 20% concentration which is
the best then there are several topical
antimicrobial creams that are available
but the most commonly used is topical
clindamycin it gives a good result and
I'll leave a link below to a triple
combination containing benzoyl peroxide
adapt lean and clean de maiz in
inappropriate concentrations if we look
at create three acne from here onwards
things get serious you have not used on
your face now and you have to start
taking oral medications and the most
commonly used drug worldwide are as I
threw my sin roxas I clean minocycline
or isotretinoin among others now which
drug you should take depends upon a lot
of factors that is why I'd made
simplified I always recommend consulting
your local practitioner or MD
dermatology before taking any medicine
now topical medicines are the same as
that of the previous two benzoyl
peroxide in combination with salicylic
acid as alloc acid and retinoids like
adapt lean applied twice daily on your
face if you have grade for acne you need
to consider taking oral isotretinoin
this is the main drug for the treatment
of these type of acne and is usually
started at ten to twenty milligrams per
day and gradually increased up to 40
milligrams in addition to isotretinoin
you should also take oral antibiotics
like tetracycline or macrolides like
azithromycin in stage 4 acne we you also
use intralesional corticosteroids which
are basically using a very small syringe
to inject steroids like tramps and alone
directly into the acne cyst
other treatment options for severe acne
include oral dapsone oral contraceptives
for females and comment on extraction so
this was in a nutshell how to treat acne
now let's look at some of the best
lifestyle changes and add home remedies
that you can do and that will help you
to decrease the severity of your acne
reduce a number of outbreaks and if you
are taking medicines for acne these
lifestyle changes will definitely
improve your results of the medication
and the first one of them being your
diet lets directly look at some of the
food that worsens acne and or causes new
outbreaks dairy products especially
skimmed milk spicy food fast food whey
protein powder refined sugars carbonated
soft drinks they all cause acne or they
can exaggerate your already existing
acne avoid these foods in your diet and
find a good replacement now let's talk
about some of the powerful home remedies
for treating mild to moderate acne at
home conventional acne treatments can be
expensive and often have undesirable
side effects like dryness redness or
irritation this has prompted many people
to look into how to cure acne naturally
at home the internet is filled with
suggestions let's look at five of these
home remedies for acne that are backed
by science
the number one of them is applying apple
cider vinegar to your face apple cider
vinegar is made by fermenting apple
cider or the unfiltered juice from press
apples like other vinegars it is known
for its ability to fight many types of
bacteria and viruses apple cider vinegar
contains several organic acids that have
shown to kill Propionibacterium acnes it
contains lactic acid and succeeding acid
which are known to suppress inflammation
caused by this bacteria and also help to
dry up the excess oil that causes acne
in the first place
how to use it mix one part of apple
cider vinegar and three parts of water
use more water for sensitive skin after
cleaning gently apply the mixture to
skin using a cotton ball and let it sit
for 5 to 20 minutes and then rinse with
water and pat dry repeat this process
one to two times per week as needed it
is important to note that applying apple
cider vinegar to your skin can cause
burns and irritation so it should always
be used in small amounts and diluted
with water
number two is to take a zinc supplement
zinc is an essential nutrient that's
important for cell growth hormone
production metabolism and immune
function it is also one of the most
studied natural treatments for acne
research shows that people will acne
tend to have lower levels of zinc in
their blood and then those with clear
skin several studies have shown that
taking zinc orally health reduce acne
in one study 48 acne patients who were
given oral zinc supplements three times
per day after eight weeks 38 patients
experienced and eighty two hundred
percent reduction in acne the optimal
dosage of zinc for acne has not been
established but several studies have
shown a significant reduction in hackney
using thirty to forty five milligrams of
elemental zinc per day
number three is to make a honey and
cinnamon mask studies have found that
applying antioxidants through the skin
is more effective at reducing acne than
benzoyl peroxide and reg know it's honey
and cinnamon also have the ability to
fight bacteria and reduce inflammation
which are two factors that trigger acne
how to make a honey and cinnamon mask
you just have to mix two tablespoons of
honey and one teaspoon of cinnamon
together to form a paste after cleaning
apply the mask to your face and leave it
on for 10 to 15 minutes rinse the mask
off completely and pat your face dry
number four is to take a fish oil
supplement omega-3 fatty acids are
incredibly healthy fats that offer a
multitude of health benefits you must
get these fats from your diet but
research shows that most people who eat
a standard Western diet don't get enough
of them fish oil contains two main types
of omega-3 fatty acids
eCos aprenden weak acid and
docosahexaenoic acid epa benefits the
skin in several ways including managing
oil production maintaining adequate
hydration and preventing acne high
levels of epa and DHA have been shown to
decrease inflammatory factors which may
reduce a risk of acne the number fifth
tip that you can follow in your home is
to exfoliate regularly exfoliation is a
process of removing the top layer of
dead skin cells and it can be achieved
mechanically by using a brush or scrub
to physically remove the cells
alternatively it can be removed
chemically by applying an acid that
dissolves them exfoliation is believed
to improve acne by removing the cells
that clog up pores it is also believed
to make acne treatment for the skin more
effective by allowing them to penetrate
deeper once the topmost layer of skin is
removed now like I mentioned earlier
guys you can get the ultimate guide to
remove acne by becoming a member of this
channel click the join button below to
know more thank you so much for watching
and see you in the next video